- Hello and welcome everyone
to ED Talks with Khan Academy.
I'm the chief learning
officer here at Khan Academy.
And today I'm excited to
talk to Mark Sternberg
who is the K-12 education program director
at the Walton family foundation.
So we're looking forward
to that conversation
to talk about COVID response
in education and philanthropy
as we think about what lies ahead
for schools after the
results of all of this COVID
experience that we've all been through.
Sal is going to be back on Friday,
his guest will be chess world
champion, Magnus Carlsen.
So look out for that.
As we think about COVID
we also want to recognize the sponsors
who have stepped up and helped us
make it through the COVID
times here at Khan Academy
including Bank of
America, AR&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and general motors.
Thank you for your support.
And with that, let's dive right in.
So first let me say welcome.
Thanks for coming and joining us today.
- It is a pleasure Kristen to be with you.
I am no international chess champion
but I'm an education
advocate, par excellence
and I'll do my best to keep up.
- Awesome.
(chuckles)
We all have our own strengths.
- I mentioned to you off air.
I'm, I love chess though.
So I'll be tuning in on
Friday, you can be sure.
And hopefully we'll go
through some openings
or I dunno, end game.
- Yeah, I can't wait to
hear that conversation,
I think it'll be good,
but for everyone that is here today,
first let's just kick off
and tell us a little bit about yourself.
Tell us how you ended up in this position,
in your, a bit of your path to get here.
- Great, well, I'm happy
too, and in all seriousness
thank you for having me and thank you,
Kristen to you, to Sarah
and to the entire Khan
Academy family and team
for the amazing work you guys
have done for so many years
and especially frankly over the last year.
I think we'll wind up talking a bit that
in our time together.
My path into this role
runs through the classroom,
right out of college
I took a job teaching.
I work for the Walton family foundation
which is of course is based
in Bentonville, Arkansas.
I am based in Brooklyn
and I much of my life,
my professional life
before coming to Walton
was in service, public
service, Tuesday city
and the teacher right out of
college as a school leader,
a school founder started a high school
that I led for six years in the Bronx,
the Bronx lab school,
and then as a policymaker
serving as a deputy to chance for crime
in the last term that the
Bloomberg administration.
So my, I cut my teeth as
a pedagog as a pedagogue,
working with a group of students
then with the school community
and then in service in New
York city at the policy level
all of which have been
kind of great preparation
for this work with the Waltons
thinking about education
on the national stage.
- That's great.
Tell us just a little bit
about founding a school.
What prompted that and
what were you thinking
as you were thinking, this
is a different experience
or a new way of thinking about school
that you wanted to take?
- Well, it came from a lot of,
a lot of it came from a
desire to have impact,
which was, is a little bit in my DNA
of sort of just being a doer,
kind of the match that
lit the fire as it were
for the school was my teaching experience
where I sort of observed what educators
many educators in your community
I'm sure feel incredible passion
and energy and potential of my students
who probably taught me
a lot more in my years
of teaching than I,
especially those early years.
And I was able to teach
them a sense of wanting
to build a school community in the Bronx
especially that would
be there for students
and help them meet their full potential.
And I think fair to say,
starting teaching in the
mid nineties, in the Bronx
a sense that we could just do better,
a sense that schools were,
too often mixed about how
they were making decisions.
My school had three principals in the,
the years I was there.
So I experienced kind of on the one hand,
this radical sense of
potential for my students
who were just waiting in a sense.
And so I experienced the wonders of that,
but also the tragedy of that and felt
that coming there was a brief
interlude of grad school
between teaching and coming
back to start the school.
And I felt like, how was my calling?
I was, I was called back to come
and try to craft something very different
for high school students.
I have a high school student in,
my own is walking into the room right now.
(laughs)
- Welcome life during COVID times, yeah.
(chuckles)
- So hopefully, yeah, just keep
it a real for your viewers.
The, this was also a
moment closing the door,
that a moment of remarkable
kind of policy, opportunity
and and a window of leadership
for New York city and it's schools that,
I view as a singular
where, the city's mayor
and chancer looked out at
the landscape of options
and saw a cohort of schools
that have been failing students
for decades with graduation
rates in the teens and twenties
and basically like sick
and tired of being sick
and tired and, and looking
for a of entrepreneurs
to come in and think about
a better path forward.
- Yeah, that definitely makes sense.
Tell me a little bit
more about your role now
at the foundation and what
that entails, what you do?
- Well, education's been a huge pillar
of the Walton family's
philanthropic interest
for 30 years long before I got here.
And far into the future,
the family has cared about this work.
It's been the center of
their philanthropic strategy
and that's really about a belief.
First is education matters
that it is a central pillar
and helping communities and families
and students live, a self-determined life
and reach their full potential
and a sense that so much
of what we can do is unlock
the potential both the
students and of educators.
The center of our strategy
is looking to teachers
and looking to educators, looking to folks
who know the work the best
because they've done it,
and they've lived it for a round of ideas
about how schools and
classrooms can work differently.
And so it's really been the privilege
of a lifetime to be in a position to help,
help the family do its work.
- So tell me a little
bit about what you do.
So are you looking for opportunities
and groups too that you wanna support?
What does that look like?
- Yeah, well, so we,
what we are focused on,
I would say a few key pillars.
One at the center of
our work is the school
and a quality school.
So a lot of what we've done over the years
and will continue to do is find educators
who have ideas of a
different kind of school
where the school could
be a new charter school
a new public school
but elevating talented educators
who have in mind to to start,
either to start a school
or to become school leaders
and find their path to school leadership.
Of course, that is important.
It requires cohorts of educators,
folks who wanna come into the profession.
So investing pipelines
into the profession,
investing in community
advocacy and community voice,
so to help communities develop a vision
and a voice, what school can look like,
how school can meet them, meet
the needs of their community
which I think in this
moment of of all moments,
is critically important.
And I think, also critical at this moment
is an investment in kind
of what the future of
learning can look like
what the future of the classroom can be.
So a deep focus, we apply a deep focus
on kind of broadly innovation
and teaching and innovation
and models and what the
future can look like.
- Their lots to follow up on there.
So let me start with the thinking about,
you said, especially in these times,
and as we think about as COVID hit,
what did you see as,
how you could bring your resources
to what was happening
as COVID started in just
about a year ago this week,
we started to see a lot of impact.
- Well, I mean, our first instinct,
I think, like everybody
it took us a minute
to kind of understand the scope of this.
The fact that we now like at the end
and I hope passed the point of view about,
like how many days a week,
or it's going to be in school
or when can we get kids
back into the building?
I mean, I'm living in New York city
and what I can report to
your listeners in this town,
it's, we're sort of seeing the other side
of that discussion,
but at the beginning I
think we all thought maybe
like you digging this was gonna be muddle
through for the rest of this
so that we're now talking right.
We're deep into the
second full school year
of confronting us is just our,
I would characterize the work we have done
in the wake of COVID in parts.
First was kind of just
trying to be a resource
for leaders in folks we've worked with
and the cities in which we've worked.
So providing some
flexibility around resources
and even some additional
resources dollars.
So that school leaders can do the things
that frankly the people we're
privileged to work with.
We found them doing like
delivering books and material
and delivering meals, making sure that,
families in their community had,
hotspots to get online when
instruction moved online.
So just the first order of business for us
was just providing extra
resource to meet the moment.
And there was, we knew we
could never do everything
but we needed to do something.
So that was, that was one is that.
- Yeah, and that extra
hotspots that's been for us,
because obviously we are
an education technology organization
and we struggle with this,
part of equity is actually
getting the resources
to the students who need it most.
And we, are always thinking about,
gosh there's this whole group
of students we can't reach
because they don't have that connectivity.
So have you guys been
working on that issue?
- We have, and that's sort of a bridge
to the second big part of what we've done.
And that's sort of thinking
about through an advocacy lens,
thinking about how we
can address the needs
that became so clear
and acute at the moment.
And at the top of that list was access,
access to clear broadband
and kind of connectivity.
And even though I think
we've got good news
coming on this Christian,
I think my understanding is that
the legislation that is making its way
to the president's desk includes
some good for families that are living
on the wrong side of digital tracks.
So that's encouraging
and we're ready to celebrate that.
It's also, I think you'd agree,
a moment to just pause
and sort of acknowledge
that there are still
families in this country
that have, it's not as
they don't have access
to high-speed internet.
They have lived through the last 12 months
without high-speed internet.
And I'd like to think that there is,
I'm thrilled that there's a solution.
And we know that just because
there's shuttle resource where
this problem is not solved
there there's a lot of
work to do to get this,
to get those dollars to the right places
and to build solutions that are permanent.
I guess my reflection on this is that,
this experience has raised
awareness of problems like this.
And I think generated a lot of public will
to solve this problems.
I guess what I wanna
express to your viewers,
is I hope we can hold on to the urgency.
We feel that we don't
sort of get back to life
as usual and forget the urgency
of many of these challenges
which frankly, before COVID,
well let's just say they pre-dated COVID
and we tolerated them before COVID,
so as we moved back to life, life as usual
I hope that we can hold on to,
kind of the urgency of solving
some of these big problems.
- Definitely.
So thinking about that future,
what do you think as we look forward
are some of the things that you see
may change perfectly in
education from where we are now?
- Well, I think I'd
make a few points here.
I do think that this is a moment to grab
for a different kind of
future in the classroom.
And that future has always been something
we've been able to talk about
as long as I've been in the work
from when I was a classroom teacher
to a school leader, to a policy guy,
but it has always been
just over the horizon
and I would credit Khan Academy and Sol,
and all of your collective work
is helping us kind of
like see it more clearly.
But I think you'd agree.
It's just been like right over the edge.
- As someone who's been in for four years
that I wanna say yes,
it has always been right over the edge.
(chuckles)
- Well, so, I mean,
just generally speaking
this needs to be a moment when we grab it
and we grab it and run toward it,
where like we understand it,
not as something nice to have, but a
and necessity for the equity agenda
for the work of like honestly lifting up
the teaching profession.
I mean, you've seen the data Christian,
we'll see if it holds the right now
one in five teachers are telling us
they're not coming back to the classroom.
And that's already like on
top of a moment for a decade
when one of the critical
challenges is attracting
and retaining quality
talent in the classroom.
So we've got to make the
profession more sustainable
and kind of help teachers
be more effective.
We gotta like lift up student learning.
Like there are big leaps
forward that need to happen.
If we're gonna help
schools meet their promise
and software based solutions
need to be a part of that.
Absolutely and I think a
close observer might say
that despite some great
progress over the last decade
it just hasn't happened in some
ways teachers are telling us
that the profession has
gotten harder, not easier.
So this is a moment we've
got a going to reach
over that horizon.
You develop solutions, look
to teachers and entrepreneurs
to help us figure out what those are
and bring more coherence to the
the teaching and learning experience.
So that, I mean, I'm speaking
maybe more in generalities
than you'd like me to,
but that's our thesis and
we're excited to do our part.
- Yeah, so we've got a
question that kind of leads
to that from Facebook, Lori,
Beth Ford, Gerald says,
please define success for
students, teachers in schools.
And I think that's an interesting question
to think about what is,
if we talk about wanting
to see the changes
in teachers and students
and what is success, how
do we define success?
- Well, I mean, for us,
that success is about,
this idea of self-determination
that school's going to prepare you for,
to lead the life you wanna lead.
And I think that's got to be
at the student level,
we've got to be focused
on skill development
and did all things kind of habits of mind
and content mastery and basic skills
and numeracy and literacy
and critical thinking
that prepare students for,
can you hear me?
- Yeah, you're good.
- Okay, good, sorry.
So skill development and
mastery, content mastery.
I think we also need
to attend to the social
and emotional health of
our students as well.
I will say that,
the last year has been a massive reminder
and I'll say more candidly, a set back,
for the children in this country.
And we're gonna have to confront
that as a country and put front and center
kind of the emotional
wellbeing of students.
When we think about success.
Now, I'd like to believe that
if these things are
not mutually exclusive,
if the idea of developing hard skills
that we know are important
for a life well lab
for this idea of self-determination
of being literate and numerate
at the highest levels,
are actually quite
consistent with the idea
of like emotional wealth
of health and wellbeing.
So I think, when I think
about student success
those are the things I think about.
When I think about teacher success,
I think about moving educators
to a place where they focused exclusively
on human centered elements of pedagogy,
where we are developing
tools in the classroom
that work harder for teachers
that make their giant
their jobs and their lives easier.
They get them faster to the work
of supporting student learning
which is why the teacher
joins the profession.
So if we can do that,
they're more satisfied,
they're more effective.
Their time and energy are
more focused in centered
on the things that are of highest value.
And I think we're, I
think if we're doing that
at scale or lifting the profession up,
so those are the first
thoughts that come to mind.
- Yeah, you talked
about self-determination
for students doing what they wanna do.
I also know that in some of
the things that you talk about
in terms of the types of
innovations, you're looking for
you talk about community
driven or community demand.
How do you bring that
into the work that you do
and how do you hear the
community demand or listen to it?
- Small conversations
that are like kitchen table,
discussions with folks who
have the most at stake,
who are closest to the action
in their communities,
whether it's in the South
or in the Pacific Northwest.
And we know there's lots in
common across communities,
but every, all of these,
all of these problems
are super local.
So for us, this has been
about building a muscle
that is a listening muscle
which doesn't mean that
we're leaving our experience
and our points of view behind
the things that we've learned.
We're in fact, bringing those with us
into these conversations,
but we're, this is about,
I mean this is classic organizing
and I will say as someone who's been
in philanthropy a little while,
well I've said it, a skill
that we've got to build
it is not the natural
instinct of philanthropy
to listen first and act second.
So that's the idea sort of a
go slow to go fast, Kristen.
- Yeah Yeah, that makes sense.
I know that when you listen
sometimes you hear lots
of conflicting viewpoints.
Like I think the school reopening
has it been a case in point
about that where different people
have really different views
and think about things in different ways
and you have different stakeholders
with different interests.
Do you, how do you navigate that
and kind of try to bring people together?
- I mean, yeah.
I mean, this is the trick and the risk,
a lot of good examples of well
intentioned change agendas
that fall apart because they reach for,
absolute kumbaya consensus.
And that's, that can't
be what this is about.
I think what we,
this is about balancing
the patients listening
with the urgency of action,
and an orientation on a set
of a set of problems that,
that can be solved and that
left unsolved have a kind
of cascading pernicious effect.
So it's not, this is not an exercise of,
everybody's standing in
a circle holding hands
and agreeing on everything.
This is about, building an understanding
of the local nature of the problem
in this case, in your instance,
how do we get kids back into school?
And if we can't,
how do we do everything we can
to make sure that on
the other side of this,
we're not confronting and
a learning loss challenge
that we can't surmount.
Broadly I mean, that is the
micro version of the problem
that Walton has been solving for 30 years.
How can we get a better school
and a better educational experience
in reach for more students
in this community?
We're clear that that's our orientation
and we're looking for,
we're looking for local
partners who have frankly,
better ideas about how to do that,
because they're close to the problem
and they've lived it in their homes.
And we hope that they can invite
this in to be a resources if
they try to solve that problem.
- Great, so you talked about
innovation and community,
tell us some things that
you're excited about
or some innovative
things that you're seeing
or working on that excites you.
- Well, I'll say, let
me start with assessment
and like, kind of accountability,
I hesitate to mention the words
like it's like a
four-letter word these days.
(chuckles)
I'll just name this as a vertical
that requires new thinking
and like a deep attention
to what comes next.
And I, what I'm very
clear on that is frankly
keeping me up at night and so many hours
to get up at night is just
how perilous the moment is
for the country, as it
relates to data collection,
student performance, I
mean even absent COVID,
we're confronting, decision
points at the state
and federal level of whether
we should be in the business
of collecting students
data that allows us to have
kind of comparability to know how one set
of students is doing relative
to another set of students.
And then COVID happens.
And we're now looking at
two consecutive school years
where we're not sure what
kind of data we're gonna have.
I believe that is a massive
threat to the equity agenda
which, there just aren't
many other threats
that rise to that level of urgency.
This to me is an innovation challenge.
We are having a fight in this country
in the four corners of little
K-12 community, Kristen
and whether we should test
and that's an important discussion
that I hope lands in the right place.
What we will be doing is
thinking about knowledge
to capture what students know
and to capture the full
spectrum of the things
we care about as it relates
to student performance.
And this gets back to
your question earlier
the listener's question, their
social and emotional health,
their content mastery,
their skill development.
These are imagined...
(loud beep)
- Are we back?
Apologies for technical difficulties.
- You hear me?
- I can.
All right.
- Hello.
- I can hear you.
Can you hear me?
Everyone this is, yeah, 2021
(chuckles)
- Can you hear me now?
I can hear you, can you hear me?
- I can hear you.
- All right.
Yeah, are we back?
Okay.
- We're back, can you hear me now?
- We are just about out of time.
So I think we're going to leave it there.
Apologies for the last couple of minutes
of technical difficulties here
to all those folks who are listening.
Mark, thank you so much for joining us
and thank you for the work
that you're doing to support learners
and learning in these times.
- Great, thank you, Kristen.
- Thank you.
Goodbye to all of our listeners
and we look forward to
seeing you on Friday.